here's wait can i ask a question yeah
because i
i think i know more about rand than
jaron does so let's see oh okay
the gauntlet has been thrown down who
did ein rand say is the most evil man
who ever lived humanoid
that's right correct no that i know i
mean yeah so it's a it's a big deal that
emanuel kant is and
and most people don't understand why
because if you read kant there's certain
passages in context sound pretty
liberal they sound pretty he's he's for
the individual sounds like he's for the
individual
he sounds like he's for the american
revolution things like that but when you
when he actually read his philosophy and
what he's trying to defend and what he's
trying to undermine
yeah he's trying to undermine the
foundations that make
the revolution possible that make
freedom and individualism possible he's
trying to destroy the enlightenment
and the enlightenment is are those ideas
that make
freedom individualism uh feasible he's
trying to undermine reason
and without reason we're nothing we're
we're not we can't survive as a species
so and that's why she
uh thought he was the most evil person
because uh his ideas undermine the very
foundations
of what it requires to be a human being
reason and
individualism those are the things he's
trying to eviscerate
i know you've you've talked about
hoffman before
so hoffman is a modern-day attempt
to donald hoffman donald hoffman donna
hoffman is the
university of california vine
neurologist a neuroscientist something
like that
so i met him once and uh we were at it
there's one of these conferences where
you do a quick intro
you sit and you do it quick and his
introduction was i've just written a
book that proves that evolution
has conditioned us not to see reality
okay that is very content yeah and he is
basically
just presenting pseudoscience to defend
kant's position about uh epistemology
and about and about metaphysics
and there's nothing there's nothing
original there
and he puts up a bunch of equations
and he says i ran a simulation and it
proves i'm right so
uh jaron is a little bit frustrated uh
with donald hoffman's work
let me uh i'm frustrated i just think
it's completely wrong
and it is and it's it's anti-life
anti-mind anti-evolution
i think he's an anti-evolutionist at the
end and i think it
you know anytime you say look here's the
important point anytime you say reality
doesn't exist
or that you won't perceive it well who
are you what do you mean by
what any of your words mean what does
anything you say even mean if it doesn't
refer to something that's
actually out there in reality let me try
to defend this point of view because in
in uh in a certain kind of sense i hear
it as a
being humble in the face of the
uncertainty that's around us
sort of uh you know when you speak with
the confidence
of iran and and yourself that
reason can be like this weapon that cuts
through all the of the world
and makes us like have an ethical moral
life and all those kinds of things
you kind of assume that uh reason is a
superpower
that has no limits wait i'll call down
okay but but i got this one
[Laughter]
see this is already leading to uh murder
by words
yeah and we've been only talking
together we're
going to get along together on an island
we just make him our slave
we're all going to get along he's just
going to do the work but i'm afraid i
cannot
provide any value as a slave so this is
this is not going to end well for me
my value is dinner that's the problem
i'm trying to get that's a solution
[Laughter]
uh well okay but donald hoffman says
that there is uh
like he he makes an argument that
exactly as you said that the the what we
perceive
uh is not is very very far from
actual physical reality in fact we're
not able to perceive
uh the physical reality at all and
he also makes the bigger claim that
evolution
uh prefers beings
who are not attached to reality so like
evolution created creatures that are
basically
functioning way outside of what that's
okay now
i got this i got this okay because
there's a lot to unpack here and i hate
all of it
okay first of all no no i'm serious
first of all when you're making that
comment about how
you know reason is a superpower beyond
limit
you're being ironic but it's true and
i'll give you one example which is
astronomy
if you look at the physical size of the
universe it's
literally in one sense incomprehensible
so he's right in the sense that
i do not understand and none of us
understand what it means for 93 million
miles away for the sun to be it makes no
it's a number on
the screen right that said the fact that
my mind and i'm not one of the great
thinkers of all time
is close but we're getting there uh is
capable of appreciating what the sun
means
what heliocentrism means um the fact
that we can
you know you're a math person that you
could look at galaxies and reduce it to
10 to the 64th power in terms of
distance
that shows the unlimited capacity
of the human mind and reason number one
number two is
if he says that evil that evolution
favors
those who are not in touch with reality
and i don't know in what context he's
saying that because that sentence could
mean a lot of different things
evolution is what guides reality is what
guides evolution
evolution works because you are fitted
to the reality of the situation around
you it's not that someone is sitting
down and says well
i'm gonna add a fin to this animal and
that finn helps it swim
swim i engineer a checkmark it's that
mutations occur the vast majority of
mutations are against reality
they do not further this animal's life
or this plant's life or this fungus's
life
but the ones that are in touch with
reality such as
okay it's really cold here there's no
predators here
if i could figure out i'm using that
term very loosely a way
where i could survive in the cold i
don't have predation
it's really great so the fact that
unconsciously and mindlessly
this process can force the mutation and
evolution of the form
precisely means that they're in touch
with reality now if he means
the consciousness is not in touch with
reality
that's another thing that i really hate
you're referring to the reality is like
the biological reality of evolution
but all of that is based on many other
layers of abstraction that
ultimately has quantum mechanics
underneath it all and he's saying
somewhere along the layers
you start to lose more and more and more
attachment to the action
one more sure sure i do not i despise
the idea
i say despise i'm not using this i'm not
joking and i the idea
that the reality we don't live in is
somehow more real
than this that is a very dangerous idea
to say
well quantum works in this way and i'm
sure he's correct and none of us
disagree with that
what we perceive macro works in a
different way well that's the real
reality and this is fake
this is the real reality that
is a different type of
a sub-subset but no one's living there
well and it's just
humanity is the starting point it's a
subset that that has to
integrate with this world there isn't
two worlds one in the quantum world and
one here
they're integrated now we might not have
the scientific knowledge to know how
they're integrated
but so what we know that there's only
one reality and that's this one
he he has this difference he says
evolution
um matches up to fitness not to reality
and he creates this dichotomy between
fitness and reality but that's complete
nonsense there is no such thing
as a concept of fitness outside of
fitness to what
to reality the fitness and reality are
the same thing they're not
separate things so the whole way he sets
this up intellectually
is wrong i think to some extent
dishonest
and certainly philosophically corrupt
and it's conscient again
he's accepted kant's ideas and and and
everybody pretty much has accepted
constant ideas for the last 200 years
and they keep it they give it a
different facade and he's giving it an
evolutionary facade
but it's just a facade for the same idea
and that is that somehow because we have
eyes
we cannot see because uh the the light
waves are going through a medium and
that medium
necessarily distorted the medium changes
the resolution at which you see
right like if i take up my glasses i'm
seeing it a little differently
but the thing is still there and the
thing is still there in the way i see it
because the handle i'm grasping the
handle and lifting the cup
that's not an illusion that is a real
cup so do you do you think some things
are more real than others for example
money
there's a bunch of things that uh seem
real
this is not an animal farm reference
there's nothing as real as love right
lex
love is a fundamental part of the
quantum mechanics yes
no no no no is there some things that
have or become reality because we humans
in a collective sense to believe it you
can't believe something collectively now
it
doesn't become real what does it mean to
say something's real that is
you can so love for example love's a
good example right love is an
abstraction
right it's not it's not something i can
touch it's not something i can see
but it's certainly something you would
feel not something you could have
we love differently i don't know i think
of the story
you can't love is love is an abstraction
so is it lovely oh yes it's real because
i i feel it
it's an existent but it's not existent
in the same sense as this cup is
so you know abstractions
are real but at the end of the day all
abstractions have to be able to
be you know you know reduced to
actual concrete so you can either see
that i
i really don't like criticizing someone
who's work i haven't read
second hand so i want to take this away
from speaking about him personally
because i'm not familiar with his work
but he's a nice guy that makes me like
him that makes him like him less
i think now you're back talking about
fitness evolutionary fitness i think
there's um uh disingenuousness
when we talk about the word real in
terms of ideas are real
versus the cup is real and you try to
switch back into
between those two meanings and it's a
little bit of linguistic
uh word play that is trying to force a
point that's not accurate
in my opinion well i think the issue is
and what he's challenging is and what
context challenging is do
we know reality and i think the answer
is
yes we do we know reality we observe it
we now do we know
everything about reality no we we can't
for example sense what a bats
bat senses as reality right a bat
observes reality through
what is it sound waves right through
sono
right so it has a different sense but
it's the same reality it
it's still a table if the bat's spatial
relationship to the table is different
than ours
but the object is still the same object
but how do you know that's true
are are you not just hoping that's true
but that's assuming this
no that's what no means no means i have
identified an aspect of reality
that's literally the definition of
knowledge now if you say how are you
certain
well that's a whole other question but
one of the reasons i know it was certain
is because this happens yes
okay and i know this is gonna happen and
if i tell if i tell you if you go
downstairs
you're gonna see you know mr jones and
you walk downstairs and i see mr jones
at the very least you know something's
going on there
you